[Applaudissements]
historique
la municipalité qui bascule à gauche un
espoir caressait depuis un an par ce
nouveau maire qui a encore du mal à
réaliser
personne n'avait réussi à faire un
deuxième tour sur lens depuis 1989
déjà c'est un exploit d'arriver au
deuxième tour et c'est un deuxième
exploit de gagner largement ce deuxième
tour oui forcément ému parce que c'est
un changement dans ma vie puisque
j'étais kinésithérapeute je vais
abandonner mon métier pour me consacrer
entièrement à la mairie de lens c'est un
vrai bol d'oxygène qui arrive sur la
ville en jeu pour que la ville se tourne
vers le 21e siècle pour répondre aux
défis économiques environnementaux et
sociaux qui attendent la ville demain
des scènes de joie pour ces électeurs
qui ont appelé au changement à 52%
christophe bois veut comprendre sa
défaite et espère faire entendre sa voix
en tant qu'opposition je peux pas dire
que je suis heureux je suis forcément
déçu parce qu'on
quand on fait quand on mène un combat on
pense toujours
20 contenance par athènes donné quand on
défend des idées
après voilà je pointe le maire sortant
jacques pélissard prend connaissance des
résultats
215 voix d'écart seulement sur 4583
votants et 57 % d'abstention c'est plus
d'abstention vous remue tour plus
l'abstention réduit donc les gens qui
sont dépassés selon la formule de
monsieur ravier voulait le changement et
en deux volets le changement vous êtes
peut-être plus moitié pour vous déplacer
pour aller voter
monsieur bois peut-être été victime de
cette faible participation de gens qui
étaient peut-être moins motivés pour
produire après 31 ans la ville change de
visage ce soir celui de jean yves ravier
s'affiche en ravit l'aboutissement d'un
an de campagne et le début d'un long
travail en matière d'éco logique de
solidarité et de démocratie
participative
[Applaudissements]